Sexual deception is a biological bummer - at
least for the party that is deceived.
Male solitary orchid bees are the unfortunate
victims of the ultimate sexual trick.
Unlike their communal-living relatives, solitary
bees do not have easy access to sexual partners.
Males must rely on distinctive airborne chemical
cues in order to find a female mate.So what
happens when a male picks up the scent of
a sexy lady - only to find it’s not another
bee...or an animal at all?
The majority of examples of sexual deception
come from members of the orchid family.
This kind of mimicry has evolved independently
on at least four continents, and its existence
continues to perplex evolutionary biologists
and botanists alike.
But why would a plant want an animal to have
sex with it?
Many plants require animals (or other interventions)
for cross-pollination (reproduction), and
sexual deception is thought to have evolved
from plants that offer food rewards to pollinating
insects.
However - in the case of this sexual deception
- after the bee does his “pollination thing,”
instead of receiving a food gift, the duped
male suitor loses his energy, time and in
some cases, his sperm.
And obviously gets no offspring.
Orchids are able to synthesize scents that
are exact replicas of sexually active female
bees.
The accuracy of this chemical mimicry is astounding,
and this is undoubtedly what initially draws
the male’s attention.
But the disguise doesn’t stop at the orchid’s
smell.
Deceptive orchids have remarkable colors and
structures that render them nearly identical
to female bees (well, at least in the eyes
of the male bees having sex with them).
The shape of the flower, its UV reflectance
and size all mimic different parts of a sexually
receptive females’ body.
Once a male has located his orchid lover,
he will engage in ‘pseudocopulation’:
a variety of behaviors including full out
sexual action and ejaculation.
Males will erect their genital capsules and
make convulsive movements, rubbing them against
various parts of the flower.
But all is not lost for our misguided bachelors.
Solitary bees have a sexual system in which
males are polygynous.
They mate with many females during their reproductive
lives.
If they happen to sex a few flowers on the
way to finding true love, there’s usually
more than enough sperm to go around.
So don’t worry little bee, you’ll get
there eventually.
Want to see more animal videos?
Then check out this playlist from our friends
at The Dodo.
Don’t forget to subscribe, and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.